Jason is on Twitter debut consider a
physical asset like gold or silver to be
equal to having an emergency fund
absolutely not it's the worst possible
place to put an investment but certainly
an emergency fund see you got any
understand gold is not really a physical
asset you know that that's a misnomer
the only reason that gold has value is
that someone else will buy it if a block
of granite someone else would buy it
then it's you know and would pace what
they would pay for a block of gold then
it's just a transfer of an item but
there is no intrinsic value in gold
meaning it has no actual functional
value in any more than a block of
granite does it's just that the
marketplace is determined they're
willing to pay you so much per ounce but
you're not any more safe because you
have a rock sitting in your safe then
you had paper money sitting in your safe
that's not there's no more there's no
physical asset here yeah now physical
asset is real estate that is that does
have a physical asset to it but because
it has a function and it creates income
blocks of gold you know gold rocks do
not create income and so absolutely not
no you do not put any money in gold or
silver but certainly not your emergency
fund I own zero gold except some cool
cufflinks that's it
zero and if you will look up gold and do
a little bit of a historical study on it
you will see it is a very very volatile
high risk investment it goes way up when
people are scared and greedy and it goes
way down when everybody gets comfy and
it's way down right now compared to
where it was about two years ago and so
you lost your butt on it I mean if you
bought a single stock that was as
volatile as that and I told you to do it
you all be screaming at me to be lynched
put a single stock on the exact same
risk pattern the exact same increase in
decrease in value as a block of gold but
no it's gold so it's all okay because
it's mysterious it's not mysterious at
all it's a gold rock that's all it is
it's a mineral it does not have
intrinsic value the only reason it has
value is that other humans place value
on it that's all
it's a spiritual transaction a
transaction of trust
the only reason green pieces of paper
with presidents faces they don't have
any intrinsic value the only reason they
have value is your trust and that's a
spiritual transaction you trust that if
I have a green piece of paper with Uncle
Ben's face on it I can do about a
hundred dollars worth of business most
anywhere and it's still accepted in most
places all that right you know that's
what you're facing so no no no don't
fall into the gold mythology the
mysteriousness of gold the meal break